Welcome to the Hugging Face Course! This
course has been designed to teach you all
about the Hugging Face ecosystem: how to
use the dataset and model hub as well as
all our open source libraries. Here is
the Table of Contents. As you can see,
it's divided in three sections which become
progressively more advanced. At this stage,
the first two sections have been released. The
first will teach you the basics of how to use
a Transformer model, fine-tune it on your own
dataset and share the result with the community.
The second will dive deeper into our libraries
and teach you how to tackle any NLP task. We are
actively working on the last one and hope to
have it ready for you for the spring of 2022.
The first chapter requires no technical knowledge
and is a good introduction to learn what
Transformers models can do and how they could be
of use to you or your company. The next chapters
require a good knowledge of Python and some basic
knowledge of Machine Learning and Deep Learning.
If you don't know what a training and validation
set is or what gradient descent means,
you should look at an introductory course such as
the ones published by deeplearning.ai or fast.ai.
It's also best if you have some basics in one
Deep Learning Framework (PyTorch or TensorFlow).
Each part of the material introduced in this
course has a version in both those frameworks,
so you will be able to pick the one you are
most comfortable with. This is the team that
developed this course. I'll now let each of
the speakers introduce themselves briefly.